good afternoon everyone welcome to the
inaugural inaugural event of the Steiner
speaker series I'm Dan Martin interim
dean in the College of Fine Arts I want
to begin today by giving my special
thanks to the school of drama especially
Allison poppin check David Randolph
Peter Cook Marianne Weems and the
creative team on the Alice project for
making the cha ski theatre available for
us today I don't know whether you know
about this or not but there's a very
large team of actors writers designers
video artists and other others working
on this they've been collaborating all
year on developing a new work on the
Lewis Carroll stories and they are in
the middle of final rehearsals
performances begin next Thursday and I'm
so grateful for them making the space
available for us today and I invite all
of you back next weekend to see this
this innovative interdisciplinary
production it's very special indeed
before introducing our featured speaker
nelle nugent i think it's important that
we recognize the generosity of sylvia
and david steiner who's endowed gift to
makes this lecture series possible and
to do those honors I now introduce
President Jerry Cohen Carnegie Mellon
University
thank you very much Stan and thank you
all for being here on this lovely
Pittsburgh spring afternoon I'm
delighted to be here to celebrate this
first lecture of our new Steiner speaker
series the series is made possible
through a very generous gift by alumnus
David Steiner and his wife Sylvia I'm so
pleased at David a graduate of our
carnegie institute of technology
engineering here at Carnegie Mellon and
Sylvia are here today to mark this
occasion with us I'll be introducing
them to you in just a moment the vision
for the steiner speaker series is to
bring to campus leaders in the
entertainment and cultural industries we
could not think of a more appropriate
person than nelle nugent it was one of
theaters most successful producers to
serve as our first speaker the signer
speaker series builds on the impact of
Carnegie Mellon people are alumni our
students and our faculty in the
entertainment and cultural industries
there's a long and proud tradition of
actors writers producers artists
technologists and designers from
Carnegie Mellon who have made their mark
on stage in film or behind the scenes
our impact in the entertainment world
stems of course from our strength in the
arts but it's also the result of our
wonderful interest is interdisciplinary
culture that sets apart everything we do
at Carnegie Mellon combining expertise
in the arts with technology and with
business as well as other disciplines is
simply part of the DNA of this
University the career path of David
Steiner is a perfect example recently I
was an event with David and he
introduced himself as a Carnegie Mellon
civil engineer I like that I'm a civil
engineer too that's an applause line cyl
engineers all right
introduce himself is a Carnegie Mellon
civil engineer who became a builder who
became an owner of a major film studio
steiner studios in case you don't know
Steiner Studios is the first and largest
studio of its kind in New York City both
David and Sylvia are also great patrons
of the Arts so it's no surprise that
David and Sylvia would want to enhance
the educational experience of our
students by establishing a lecture
series centered on topics related to
entertainment the entertainment artistic
and cultural industries in fact over the
years david has personally mentored
students in Carnegie Mellon's masters of
entertainment industry management
program through annual internships at
the steiner studios in New York that
program by the way is a joint program
between our College of Fine Arts and our
Hines College something else distinctive
about Carnegie Mellon having such joint
programs we are very grateful to David
and Sylvia Steiner for their commitment
to the University and for their gift to
create this new lecture series and now
I'd like to ask sylvia and david to join
me here on the stage
David and Sylvia thank you very much for
your generous gift to Carnegie Mellon
for the Steiner speaker series and for
all of your wonderful support which has
come in so many forms throughout the
years we have a small token of our
appreciation for each of you they would
like to present to you now yeah so
people can see this a little bit hard to
see from the back but as you all know
Andy Warhol is an alumnus of Carnegie
Mellon and these are Warhol is a shins
if that's the right word for up David
and Sylvia and they're beautiful thank
you so much
and if you would I'd like to invite
David to say a few words David thank you
thank you I'm excited to be here today
to inaugurate the speaker series a
program that I know will bring in people
from the world of theater film in the
arts to share their life experiences
with you I think it's a program that
fits in so well with the educational
program and the education you're
receiving here at CMU I was very
fortunate to have attended Carnegie Tech
which is what I still call it studying
civil engineering as the doctor told you
and receiving an education that has
served me well in my life's work I was
thought that in life I would encounter
problems whose solutions were behind
locked doors my professors instead of
giving me a bunch of keys to carry
around openly stores would help me build
a key making machine that I could
utilize to open the locked doors and
solve the problems I'm grateful to CMU
for that education and I trust that each
and every one of you will come away from
your experience here at CMU similarly
equipped to face the future thank you
very much
okay now to the main event I I won't
take but a moment to introduce nelle
nugent as i like all of you or am eager
to hear what this producer in general
manager of Broadway's most influential
and successful productions over the last
40 years has to say but i was talking
with a first-year student in the lobby
moments ago and he said what important
Productions has nelle nugent been
involved with and and i was stunned for
a couple of moments ticking off in my
mind the sheer volume of her
accomplishments and I said you know what
it'd be far easier and faster to just
tell you which ones she hasn't been
involved with but but then I couldn't
think of a single production to include
on that list it's important to note
though that nelle nugent in addition to
bringing artists and audiences together
in the theater has had a tremendous
career champion championing musical
artists opera productions dance
companies film productions and
television productions she's made great
contributions on all fronts friends it
is an honor to officially welcome an
adventurous and i would say courageous
leader in the entertainment industry ms
Nell Nugent
thank you
hi all you soggy wrinkles people guy I
hear it's been raining for a month here
how do you handle it I mean I feel
mushrooms been growing behind my ears
since the plane landed anyhow it's
lovely to see you thank you all for
coming out in this wild weather I've
worked with so many grads of CMU over
the years that I almost feel I've been
here I'm and it's been very welcoming
I'm here because Sylvia and David
Steiner asked me to be here and be the
inaugural speaker and elektra series
that they endowed there's a little
pressure there fellas thank you oh yeah
see after anyhow um Dean mar Dean Martin
isn't that funny d Dan Martin asked me
to come up with a theme for my speech
and I took a while and I know the
audience is quite diverse so I thought
what could I possibly talk about that
would interest any everybody and I
settled on one of the two mantras of a
book written in 1982 by Bill William
Goldman who's a screenwriter on the
everybody's a list he was almost drummed
out of Hollywood for the book because it
was so truthful it was called my
adventures in the screen trade which was
obviously a parody of the Dylan Thomas
adventures in the skin trade and there
were two mattress in it one story is
structure and those of you who are
writers or producers and directors
ignore that one at your peril but the
other one and this is the one that got
him in trouble was nobody knows anything
and nobody does ah and I think it's
important to remember that because it's
creative people or people who are
interested in the arts or patrons of the
Arts nobody really does know anything
I'm sure those of you who've taken art
history courses have heard about the
salon de lef is a the academy review in
Paris
in the mid 19th century refused
paintings by the Al Hawke Gog and so
they came up with a salon of themselves
and call it the salon de Graaff music
which meant the rejected the people who
rejected and the lead pony in that one
was a man named Eduardo a nobody knew
anything then but years later you have
to sometimes be patient as an artist
what nobody knows anything really means
I think is that there are no algorithms
or combination thereof there's no magic
formula there is no crystal ball that
can absolutely predict success whether
it's for a film a play any kind of
worker art or even a person there's just
no way to do it everything defies the
odds yeah there are some things yeah
avatar is going to be a hit and it was
but a lot of other things are either
ahead of their time behind their time or
just lousy in the first place but nobody
knows which is which we all spend a lot
of money with focus groups particularly
in the film industry focus groups stats
statics exit polls distributors networks
everybody's pulling everybody else but
you might as well use a divining rod
it's just as predictable I mean the
Burnett report comes out every year
about television predicts with great
positive thrust what the hit television
shows are going to be be the next fall
and all of the advertisers buy into it
and buy the hot shows and more often
than not the hot show is not the hot
show there's a show that comes out of
nowhere who would have thought I'd show
about to massively obese people would be
a big hit this season it was and is and
it's renewed who would have thought a
showtime series about a woman dying of
cancer would be a great comedy it was
and it is nobody knows anything so um I
think that that you also have to realize
that I don't know anything either
my remarks today I could change my mind
tomorrow because circumstances may
dictate it by changing my mind but what
it really means to the artist or the
people who support artists is that you
can't be discouraged by all those people
saying no you are really listening for
the yes and sometimes the only one who's
saying yes is you learning to trust
yourself is a very big deal and it's
very very hard when you're very very
young because being accepted is so
important I was extremely lucky I was at
a father who encouraged nonconformity
you know why do you have to wear that
long poodle skirt everybody's wearing
long protal skirts I said well because
everybody is no you're not and I didn't
get a poodle skirt ruined my life for
about six minutes you know I was talking
to some friends the other night ran a
sous bras de and randy adams it took
them nine years to get memphis the
musical to broadway it took wendy
Finerman 14 years to get a studio to
commit to Forrest Gump you know
persistence does pay off fellas you
really have to if you believe in
something you stick with it persistence
pays off it's one of my mattress I think
you also have to realize and I started
to hint about it that art and
entertainment are products of a time and
a place on the simplest level something
that might be wrong for one platform or
one area or when Europe might not might
work in another so it's very important I
think for those of you who are artists
creative artists of any kind to think of
what's the best first use of your
brainchild something that
may be wonderful in theatre might not
work in cyberspace something that might
be perfect for cyberspace might be awful
for a film but how about something that
you created might not work for ABC
family but would work fine on lifetime
knowing your possible market knowing
where your work will be best accepted
first is a really important thing and
how do you learn that you keep up with
what's going on who's buying what those
of you who are our visual artists
they're probably watching the galleries
in New York and seeing who's buying what
are watching Art Basel or aren't Miami
those of you who are in film are
watching what's working and what's not
and it's very important to realize
what's going on in the world because
first of all you don't want to be a
copycat but you do want to understand
what people are interested in that's
where the nobody knows anything comes in
because people don't always know what
they're interested in storia structure
is a truism and so is the creative
accounting that Studios do that
guarantee no film ever made ever made
any money but everything else is pretty
much up for grabs and I believe that
sincerely but if it's going to work as
an art it has to be a business Sir Henry
Irving 19th century English actor
manager said if it cannot succeed as a
business it will fail as an art that is
really really important to remember
because public acceptance or acceptance
on some level will keep you as the
artist going now does that mean that we
producers have to only do tried and true
revivals fluffy comedies copy cat shows
jukebox musicals only engage people who
with track records well of course not
dilution and mimicry are no good they
don't guarantee
success at all and remember somebody
produced Edward Albee the first time
someone took a chance and a genius was
discovered producers producers to my
mind are the ultimate entrepreneurs we
are Buccaneers we're men and women with
a script under our arm and a passion we
have in our own way I believe the same
passion that creative artists have what
do i do I make people's dreams come true
and that means that i find a project and
nurse it to fruition no matter how long
it takes me I'm listening for that yes
and not the know if I find a play that I
love I'll do it if I can think how to
market it the business side if I can't
figure out how to market it I don't do
it and so I lost some plays along the
way I passed on torch strong trilogy and
that day and age I couldn't figure out
how to market it I passed on agnes of
god I just didn't like it
please but you know I'm not the only one
I Cheryl Crawford great woman producer
one of the early ones the head of me
passed on a show called gangland USA
what was the eventual title of gangland
USA anybody got it I'm sorry nobody
knows anything ABC passed on I'm sorry
ABC passed on The Sopranos um et went
into turn around it's just a matter of
hanging on and you'll get there so I'm
the independent crass commercial
producer who does make dreams can come
true I find ways to get a script that I
love or a creative person's concept out
there in front of the public and it's
not an easy task because there are no
hard and fast rules I mean those of you
who are going into or have been in film
and television realize that there are a
lot of gatekeepers now in the film world
the executive gets up every morning with
one mission in mind to keep his or her
job no I'm serious that's exactly what
they do they got a cup in the morning
say I've got to keep my job today
because if you read write or watch any
of these things the turnover at studios
is very very high same in television so
how are you going to keep your job
you're going to keep your job by not
taking risks because it's been proven oh
it's been proven over and over again I
better go over here it's been proven
over and over again that the that 90
plus percent of the nose are correct so
if you say no all the time you'll be
right most of the time and that'll be
good so you'll keep your job however
that also means that tons of studio
executives
Chris thank you thank you Chris so a
studio executive faced with Robert
Redford's first picture a decision about
Robert Redford's first picture and he
directed in years which he was also
going to star in and to which in which
he got Tom Cruise and Meryl Streep to
star everybody remember the title it was
awful but the studio executive who
greenlit that show that film which was
called I can't remember something about
lamb that's exactly right wasn't it
god-awful they produced the deal they
didn't produce the film so the point is
is that studio executive didn't get
fired of course he didn't get fired it
was Robert Redford Meryl Streep and Tom
Cruise one me so that's not a place
where we take risks people take risks
who are independent there the int what's
why we love the indie film so much
that's why we love the the odd theatre
project that's why we like the odd
television show these are the things
that excite us it's a little bit
different a little bit edgy it's a
little bit out there and the next year
you know there'll be a zillion copycats
of it it's the bay the way the business
works so between all the rejection and
persistence pays off there is also
something else that you ought to keep in
mind you can accomplish almost anything
if you don't mind who takes credit for
it don't laugh it's very important that
studio executives television executives
even creative people feel and owned the
ideas you want them to feel they own the
ideas so if you slit something in that
came around that you put it in a way
that they took ownership and it gets
your project done or gets your project
funded what do you care you're the hero
you gotta
funded so there's plenty of credit to go
around for a success and as we all know
failure is a major orphan so you can
afford to be generous it isn't always
about me me me it's about them it's
about what can comfort level can you
give the funder what comfort level can
you give the collector what comfort
level can you give an investor what
comfort level can you give a creative
person to make a major cut in material
he or she loves to change the direction
of a character it has to be their idea
or they can't write it it has to be
their idea or they can't shoot it and
God forbid you should ever force an
actor down a director's throat it'll be
the worst performance you ever saw
because the director will not know how
to communicate with that artist and the
artist will feel it so it's a lose-lose
it's a double lose yes compromise and
creative creative persuasion is very
much part of the producers job you guys
remember a film there were two films
both with similar themes one was called
wag the dog and the other was called
bullets over Broadway what did the guy
want that got him killed in both in both
films credit the wag the dog remember
they shot him because he knew too much
and the same thing I'm with I think it
was Chazz pammy Thierry in bullets over
Broadway they wanted the credit they
didn't want to be anonymous anymore so
they got shot dead those are two
independent films and both of the
filmmakers had a sly I because they were
making something that had a second-tier
a kind of response from those of us in
the business some of you are still
students some of you are beyond students
I see but you know at this at almost any
stage of your life you have the
opportunity to look around and change to
have a look around and think
I was asked earlier how did I get to be
producing and it's a long story for
another show but the thing that is
exciting is that you're never sure where
it's all actually going for the students
you're getting a great education here I
know that as I said I've worked with so
many CMU student people grads you're
getting a great education here but the
fact that you trained as a designer or a
director or as an actor as a whatever
stage manager production supervisor
doesn't mean that's where you're going
to land up but you have been prepared
and preparation is really really really
important I knew a wonderful woman named
Dorothy Manor for those of you who know
opera or voice would know her I came to
know her after her career was over and
it was an odd career because she had a
glorious voice she peeked in about the
late 40s early 50s but there was a
problem dorothy was black and black were
not permitted in opera houses on the
stage in particular but Dorothy prepared
many many roles and had a decent career
in Europe I met her some years later in
the early 70s she found it among other
things the Harlem School for the Arts
there's a woman and I said to her dirty
why would you have prepared all those
roles knowing you might probably
wouldn't get to sing them she said but I
had to be ready didn't I so we hope
you're ready no matter what your age is
no matter what your stage in life I mean
there's a man for these days like
everybody has three different careers in
life I don't know which one I'm on but
the thing is being ready and being
prepared and how do you do that when
you're out there trying to work with
yourself well you do a lot of listening
you listen to what people are saying
what
people want you keep track of the film's
you track look watch the plays you read
books and I go to the occasional gallery
see what people are painting even look
at fashions look at what the bestseller
list is it's keeping up with what people
want now that doesn't mean that current
that currency is absolutely right but
the site dice of ears change and you
have to have your antenna up if you're
to be a creative person or a producer to
see to feel that this may be the thing
that's out there that people want
because if you're going to be a copycat
you know you can do those fill in the
numbers paintings lots of fun and it's
always always about learning isn't it I
mean you're getting out of school you've
been out of school for years but you're
always learning aren't you I was in the
elevator in my building a few weeks ago
and darling little girl's got seven was
in the elevator going down and their
mommy and I said hi you off to school
and she said yes and then she looked at
me and I had my little dress for success
outfit on and a messenger bag
shamelessly advertising my current show
on Broadway and she said are you going
to school too and I said well actually I
am I'm going to my office which is my
school because I learned so much every
day the technologies are changing the
delivery systems are changing for how we
send and receive information
entertainment how we entertain we've
learned to entertain ourselves with all
these games I'm asked constantly well
what's the future going to be I mean are
we all going to be sitting in our homes
by ourselves doing our V ods or
streaming I don't think so I mean would
you think about it rather be sitting at
home by yourself on watching in a bra
rias comedy or would you rather be
sharing it with other people's strangers
though they may be it may be more
comfort
people watching a football game steelers
go from from your living room and
actually the camera work is great but
the feeling of being there with the
energy in the ballpark a lot better
right so i don't think we're going to
lose entirely the idea of the communal
experience of entertainment so while all
of you are repurposing your material
this is very important for artists to
end producers how can I repurpose what
I've created how can that become a
webisode a moba sewed how can this be
come fill in the blank what's the future
of this can i get this work of art
working many ways across many platforms
there's a whole new discipline that's
grown up in the last couple of years
called transmedia i go to classes to
learn about it seriously and transmedia
the first film that really spoke to
transit was handled by transmedia was
avatar it was horizontally and
vertically platformed everywhere every
type of system by which that could be
disseminated was used and it worked
brilliantly so naturally they're looking
everyone's looking for the next avatar
which James Cameron is not doing because
he does not want to repeat it he will do
another film but not avatar which great
for him why does he want to do avatar to
bride of avatar son of Avatar I mean
it's a broken record so the thrill of
the entertainment business for me is its
constant change our audiences are
changing I'm thrilled to see they that
studios are also beginning to recognize
it sure their people said fried green
tomatoes who is going to see that
Driving Miss Daisy who would ever go to
see that because most films are created
particularly the summer blockbusters for
boys and men 18 to 39 so where does that
leave the rest of
us last summer there was a sneaky one
the studio obviously didn't care much
about it because you probably you hardly
knew it was out it was called red
anybody see it yeah oh the young people
saw it too so here was the marketing
boys stuck with a picture starring 360
year old pluses what are we going to do
with this very it but the audience found
it clever boots and the bargaining boys
had to respond to it and they did
respond to it's a red turned out to be a
rather good film I'm fascinated to see
that there are more films coming out
that being made for this age group where
did they think the baby boomers went are
gonna go they weren't going to get
younger so they have to be served and as
the as the population moves on and
expands we have to deal with it I'm
dealing with a play on broadway right
now that has John Leguizamo starring in
it he attracts a Latino Hispanic
audience as his top prime audience
that's a niche audience this audience is
overjoyed to be served they're flocking
to the theater having a wonderful time
now what am i doing racking my brain to
think of okay this audience has sampled
something they obviously love in a
theater a live experience what can I
give them that will bring them to try
something else so yes I'm reading a lot
of plays with this background in it I
mean we are all the same a family
stories a family sorry no matter what
color the family is I mean fiddler on
the roof how many Jews do you think
there are in Nacogdoches Texas seriously
speaking we sold out on the tour one of
the many tours of Fiddler on earth which
had not produce I was production
supervisor we saw that a week in
Nacogdoches Texas it was a family story
about tradition about a father letting
go of his beloved daughters it's totally
Universal it's telling a good story
that's what we in entertainment do
that's what artists do
a painting tells a story a sculpture
tells a story a film tells a story a
play tells a story and if it's a damn
good story and you market it well you'll
have an audience you'll make a business
of it there will be profit for you and
your investors and success and fame for
your author which is also very good I
think that one of the things that set
the big thing that separates the theater
from film and television is distribution
film needs a lot of distribution theater
you need one so there are more risks
taken in theater and for the purpose for
people who like to risk theater is a
place where they can find great rewards
as an audience and that's why theatre
lives among the many reasons theatre
lives but you don't marketing becomes
the key to success if you can't make a
business of it meaning marketed problem
it's not going to succeed and if it
doesn't succeed then it's not going to
be done again repetition is good you
want your authors plays to be done all
over an author one success an actor want
success a director wants success but
success is measured in many many
different ways and I think those of you
who are starting out now have a better
shot at getting your work out in front
of people who could buy it support it
produce it because you have that
wonderful thing the computer you can put
together real you can contact people you
don't have to be there in person you can
put your portfolio on a disk and more
and more wonderful ways or being
invented of how we can communicate with
each other with buyers with audiences
with investors with studios more and
more and reinvented and the quicker we
are as suppliers to adapt to these
things the better off it will be for all
of us for consumer and for creator
because the distance between the
financial mindset and the creative
mindset is shrinking all the time
because creative people are now becoming
their own distributors because of that
wonderful net so they become the
business of themselves which is great so
every creative person needs a business
course you need to think of yourself as
your business because if it cannot
succeed is a business it will fail as an
art and you and your art or one the
consumer and the art are pulled together
and it's an extraordinary experience
when sorry when that happens I think if
you can retain either as a consumer or
as a creator the long over the long
course the joy of discovery of
discovering talent I mean one of the
things that isn't it wonderful when you
go to a theater or a film or you go to a
gallery and you take a deep breath that
oh my god it's wonderful I never saw it
before I never saw this actor before I
never saw this painter before it's a
discovery and if you can keep that joy
of discovery as a consumer or the joy of
creating it as a a producer I'm sorry
Isaac as a creative person if the
producer can be thrilled by serving
changing audiences and bringing great
material before the public I think
you'll have a level of satisfaction that
is not always the same thing as success
but if you remember nobody knows
anything then you keep a sense of humor
and you know in the end I think that's a
prize in itself
thank you now I know you wanted festival
we have questions I think someone is
approaching we have microphones at the
bottom of the steps on the landing if
you have some questions would like to
line up there we'd be glad to take some
questions I'm going to put in a
shameless plug first for those of you
who are in television going to
television and film there is a
state-of-the-art service in in Brooklyn
that revised revitalized a dismal
waterfront and pours a lot of money into
New York it's called Steiner Studios
shameless I've been there it's great
questions oh come on somebody's got a
question everybody goes to a lecture
with a question and approaching here
comes one here comes to high yes um oh
it's Samantha it is hi tell Samantha hi
um I was just wondering if you could
speak a little bit about since a lot of
us here are students and we're about to
enter into this sort of big scary real
world career path those of us that do
want to go into producing they do you
want to go into management what what
would you say to us what we what would
be your advice for how do how do we get
started in this what is the first very
point scary and so wonderfully prepared
I CMU scary of course look we all went
out into the great outdoors all by
ourselves as I said you are in the
business of you you and I talked earlier
about you're getting your resume out
there tailoring it for each particular
possible job opportunity the business of
you is really really important i think i
would advise every youngster to spend or
anybody you know spend at least 15
minutes a day thinking about what you're
doing why you're doing it and what are
you happy doing it and what am i doing
that makes me unhappy
I have the privilege of walking too
crazy Wheaten Terriers every morning at
six o'clock and it's a great time from
New York is very quiet then and I spend
that half hour of walking the dogs
thinking really thinking cuz they they
do whatever they do but it's important
to spend time thinking about you and
then keeping important lists of whom
you've spoken to why they said no we're
who do you know where the net is
wonderful for for finding people you
aren't anybody coming out of CMU has a
huge network of people who are very very
successful in the business and as I said
to both the president and Dean I of all
the schools they're gone to the people
I've worked with have gone to I've never
heard one grouse about those with the
lousy as four years of my life about CMU
so there's got to be a feeling there and
so you can make the contact hi I just
got out of CMU too I don't know anybody
you want to talk to would you give me 15
minutes I just want to pick your brain a
little you never know where to lead and
I'll promise you they would say no now
say maybe not this week could you call
me next week but for at least two or
three years you've got the CMU
connection to play very excellent you
also need to know who who's moving where
so if you're not reading variety or not
following where the job openings are or
where at a particular say regional
theater where you might start working
first where the head of the theater has
been replaced trust me the head of the--
to replace a lot of people are going to
be changed because the head wants to
come in with his team or her team here's
what I'm going to deal with anybody
else's team it's the same thing as a
network or in the studio the person goes
out the new person comes in the new
person has the opportunity to get rid of
everybody if he keep someone who's
underperforming or green lights a
picture that doesn't go he's an idiot
because he had the opportunity to get
rid of it so keep in MA
find that when it when a theater or a
company starts to change there's going
to be a vertical and horizontal changes
going on in there might be a place for
you so you have to keep your ears out
there you're not operating alone you are
your own business so you have to be in
the business of you and with the
computer you can keep track of it all
the time someone says no to you six
months later calm again anything open up
why not or if something changed in your
area like if for instance if you did a
great design you designers did a
fabulous design email people and say hey
I'm one of my shows is up at the Guthrie
you wanted to take a look or if you
can't here are some pictures of it let
people know they're not going to
discover it without you telling them so
you are in the business of you and no
one's going to toot your horn except for
you at first next hi how are you whoa
first of all thank you so much for being
here my name is Evan Baron i'm a senior
actor here in the school drama and i'm
interested in producing which is why i
also got a business minor here at
carnegie mellon just recently I've
received two offers from Stewart
Thompson in New York as an internship
and also at the mark Gordon company in
Los Angeles I just wondering if you
could give me some wise words of advice
about an intern going into it was really
good to get those offers because I know
both of them and they're tough so it's
not an actually got rude and tough but
top designer you know who Scott Rudin is
read the assistant it's about him it's a
novel Stewart is a really wonderful
general manager and producer he runs a
very good office 1501 Broadway from
Australia came to New York and learned
the business he's really really good and
very prolific he is strictly theatre
oriented Mark Gordon is strictly film
oriented terrific office fine producer
gets a lot done you're not going to make
a wrong choice you know you can but you
have to decide
your heart is for starters are you going
to be happy in sunny California driving
a car where there's no place I hate
California did you notice the only
random experience you can have in
California is a car crash on the Ventura
Freeway because nobody meet runs into
anybody you don't bump into each other
just nobody on the street you're
arrested if you're on the street so it's
it's you have a wonderful dilemma and
what it also is a dilemma that should be
very very empowering to you because two
very important people want you my guess
is it'll be much more hands-on in stuart
Thompson's office and I can only tell
you he's one of the most reputable in
the business a very good man there's up
after that the choice is yours thanks
much more comfortable speaking from the
left misalucha thank you for your
comments wonderful just to give us some
insight as to what might be ahead I just
love to know what project you have most
recently decide to undertake and what
was it about that project that made you
decide to take it on well those of us
are professional producers I mean that's
what we do we don't write checks just we
write checks and we produce so we have
one Coleman film and television a
development pipeline and things are at
various stages of development because
even though you think fill in the blank
is your exact next show something
happens or this is your next film
something happens and it falls out but
something else moves forward quickly so
I think I think the next play at which I
decided on some months ago is called
stick fly it was it's been done at four
regional theaters none of them I didn't
see any of them I read it and loved it
it's for want of a better description of
black morning
at seven and I'm very excited about it
because it does go into my thinking
about diverse audiences and all families
are alike you look at fiddle around the
roof you say that's my crazy parents
mornings at seven as am I crazy family
stick fly that's my crazy family so I
think that's going to be the next one
it's it's the script is ready Kenny Leon
is set to directed I have a excuse
me a slot in his schedule which a-list
directors you have to work on the
schedule so that seems to be the one
next I have a passionate about the play
it's very smart very appealing but I
have two other plays around it and we'll
see what happens we'll just see what
happens but I'm also servicing the ones
that have just been done i mean
leguizamo is a constant job of marketing
and and dealing with every day for a
certain percentage of the day and time
stands still which I also produce the
season which ended its run at the end of
January is going to London next year so
in February because that's the slot in
Dan Sullivan schedule I can get so a lot
of it is dictated not by what you want
but about what someone else wants so
that's you have to be very careful that
you don't dictate yourself into a corner
as a producer because you have to be
responsive to the talents availability
and that dictates a lot yeah hello I'm
Sarah trap now i'm a senior actor as
well um I was wondering as we're kind of
venturing out and if as a young person
when you were just starting what if you
learned one thing or what was the first
thing you learned if you made some kind
of mistake or like what was the one
thing you learned as a first coming out
young person career well if they're
paying for money for it you do it
thank you so much seriously speaking I
have been a carpenter and electrician a
box office manager I've been a costume
designer I've been an actor I've been
you name it I did it in the theater and
the thing that's so wonderful about that
is that you get to understand what the
other guys problems are you night might
be an expert in it god forbid but you do
you have walked in his moccasins a
little bit and you understand I mean
Harold Pinter started as an actor and he
still continued acting up until almost
his death but he found that writing
released more for him and working with
Harold was amazing experience because he
understood the actor in such an
extraordinary way I mean we were out of
town in Boston and the try out of this
play which Simon gray had written and
one of our partners a terribly nice man
but a little pushy was very unhappy with
the actress it would cast in a
particular role and the thing was she
had to be nude for part of the show and
and it's not an easy thing to just take
off your clothes particularly in Boston
she was from Boston and so Frank I was
charging through this past door at the
end of the first performance and
encounters Harold I said well I just
don't think lines cutting it and I've
never seen Harold turn I think buddy
know what he looks like he's kind of
forbidding it was kind of forbidding and
he turned absolutely black and said if
Miss Milgram isn't performing it's not
her fault it's mine I haven't directed
her well don't speak to me again and he
never spoke to Frank again but you know
that's an enormous responsibility that
the director takes on and it's my fault
I cast her I have to get her to a proper
performance I'm going to get there just
get out of my way so he as an actor
understood that this was taught for her
it was her first
formance before a live audience in her
hometown so naturally she was all she
eventually did beautiful performance but
the actors background taught him
something wonderful that's why his plays
work so wonderfully so you don't you the
surprises that are coming in your lives
of where this education where the next
turn is coming I'm going to be really
exciting for you and you know what
there's not a wrong answer here one
thing leads to another leads to another
I don't know anybody who's gone in an
absolute straight line but I may be a
deprived child anyone else yep I think
that's it thank you very much now
absolutely impartial recognition of your
being here today we do have a swag bag
full of Carnegie Mellon gifts including
a blanket to keep you warm in the
theaters at night there's a copy of
Randy pouches last lecture and a book on
Pittsburgh as the Paris of Appalachia so
we thank you very much
and before we join the reception in the
lobby I want to make one last thank you
to Sylvia and David for making this
series possible your support enriches
the students here tremendously thank you
please join us in the lobby for some
food and drink you're welcome to ask
nelson more questions and if you're
interested in the film industry or
what's going on at steiner studios I'm
sure David would love to talk with you
as well thank you for being here today